[Music]
new rule
no touching me
[Applause]
[Applause]
here we go there's one telling you you
can see the fun of broom come on up here
man yeah [ __ ] shredding fringes up
here alright
[Applause]
on a scale of one to ten how would you
rank yourself as a dancer one being
Elaine from Seinfeld and ten being
Michael Jackson pedophile but still the
great things
I mean one not mutually exclusive you
know what I mean
dude was a great [ __ ] dancer also
touched a lot of kids what are you gonna
do you don't hey I got it like a 1 good
Michael Jackson joke what's the
difference between Neil Armstrong and
Michael Jackson Neil Armstrong walked on
the moon and Michael Jackson [ __ ] little
boys okay
[Applause]
that is the difference between I hope
you guys
you take that joke with you tell
everybody I [ __ ] Wow 1 to 10 where do
you rate yourself as a dancer so I'll
put it to you like this imagine Gabriel
Iglesias with moves of Channing Tatum ok
that's not a number you're gonna need a
number from a scale of 1 to 10 I'll say
a solid 7 but it fits on the crack no
it's good if he thinks he's an 8 it's
good to say 7 because anybody they need
you give me a word that defines your
dance style it could be athletic okay
give me sultry I think and you know what
I'm just telling you right now it was
fake as [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm gonna go eclectic we'll go with that
it collected okay and I need the name of
your best dance movie eclectic I don't
think you're using that word right I
don't have a name for it but it won me
four dollars in Austin Texas tell
everybody your name my name's Zach
salt 7 he's gonna break out the $4
shimmy
[Applause]
won't answer the question that's going
on guys okay get your ax from the crowd
to a minute are you yeah honey Lou your
name is Leroy okay I gotta tell you man
if you had told me Leroy is coming on
stage here or not who I woulda picture
[Applause]
you like saying out loud do you wish
that was your life what's your last name
Levi Lucero
yes what's your bidding oh come on Mia
now how do you rank yourself as a dancer
that was that was a lot of sounds just
to say one one and I love this by the
way I love this strategy because he
cannot disappoint you
the one word to describe your dance
style
I got to tell you man I don't say this
lightly I'm really looking forward to
seeing you next what's the name of your
best chance permit I bet you that is
actually a great name let's call it the
I have no idea I think that because I am
a feeling when you start do it you are
not gonna really know what you do I
guess you don't know what next you're
gonna be making it up as you go it's a
perfect name yeah I have no idea which
is gonna be up against the [ __ ]
40-hour shitty so far Lera a $4 sorry
yeah she correctly she was like no way
he's worth $40
Oh
[Applause]
sporting a solid ain't cup I get
[ __ ] shake those [ __ ] around
[Music]
[Applause]
you have no idea you have no idea I
people take risks and do [ __ ] what is
your name Britney me too
so I can't [ __ ] dance okay let me I'm
gonna ask you a passionate yet
[Music]
I'm a huge fan of yours right now hear
that so much in Canada
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so good okay let me this might
take longer than it should
okay one two ten raise yourself as a
things
[Music]
shove all your boobs yet negative five
okay give me one maybe one word to
describe your dance styles
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
is there enough to go around killer now
I need to know the name a killer I need
to know the name of your best dance move
Oh like that Wow
what would apply the toner and then the
last two we're gonna win it we're gonna
be in it to win it for the rest of the
song
remember it's interpretive dance feel
the birds let them flow through your
body and this is the song you'll be
dancing you
[Music]
the
[Music]
oh go ahead I'll show your moves yep
ready no no no no it's one at a time I
know you're doing great but you want to
hold those you don't want anyone see
that's why you're going next
[Music]
I'm so glad you came up here I can't
even tell you you're ready man now
listen you might go over to the second
round so you don't know if you want to
show the four dollars yet up to you here
we go feel the words oh my god what is
happening you over my shoulder okay here
we go
you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I think Nick is the right word in
this your test sound my man just beat
all I can say is be you and you're gonna
kill this you don't have to worry about
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey new rule not touching me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Leeroy keep your dick in your pants you
seem excited to see what that looks like
you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you are these I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah Wow now that your rule keep the
[ __ ] the foot away from me on every side
[ __ ] it we're not playing like a
two-person smarter ones like you you're
all innovative you all did things that I
have not seen done before the best one
time for the
[Applause]
you're definitely going to set around
I'm super happy to hear about that well
I hate to say that because I really
enjoyed you more than you know and I'll
never forget your dance thank you so
much for coming up here man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
tell me why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's help you lie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I will tell you from where I was said
that looked pretty amazed I mean how
good did that feel to do that right in
her face liberating his [ __ ] right
you're like I never thought I would be
pushing my ass in this woman's face on a
Saturday night but if she says she she's
really needs to get out of her shell a
little bit
just shove her ass no strangers faces at
you that was amazing we're pretty good
[Applause]
passion it was really feeling the lyrics
and the evening and
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what I'm hit and even when it's
a little wrong you know it's they have
the same waitress they have the same
waitress doesn't [ __ ] count it up how
long you been holdin out of that piece
of information
dude you didn't want to say something a
little earlier the same way
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
another first Rigney you don't have to
do it
it's just one of the many sure I said
that out loud a lot of times things I
say loud I did tonight so I thought I'd
say to all of you the same time you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty quick didn't have it ready quick
Brittany we had one rule live show you
know what I mean I don't know how to
tell you that was great
you got everyone dancing you got the
whole what what do you mean II dish why
did he leave
[Music]
take it easy [ __ ]
okay y'all Noblet darkness
[Applause]
I'll [ __ ] you real good I mean I'll take
Oh where'd he go man Oh
[Music]
[Music]
and I hope you watch here I do not to
say something to him because I hope he
walks back in because I hope he doesn't
I hope something happened during engine
ticket fall yeah that was too far a
weird [ __ ] shot yo this is one of the
weirdest
ever
III can't believe it like it's a baby
it's so gray super you guys saw the
special one you saw so much
congratulations to you for choosing this
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you